das hatte trotz mäßiger vor spiele gegen
mexiko und schweden wohl kaum ein fan
der deutschen nationalmannschaft zu
fürchten gewagt die weltmeister jogis
jungs sind in kasan im letzten
gruppenspiel gegen südkorea aus der wm
ausgeschieden nach den zähen ersten 45
minuten und verpassten deutschen chancen
blieben jogis jungs in der zweiten
halbzeit weiter bemüht aber ohne erfolg
deutsche fans konnten nur verzweifeln
daran konnten auch sechs plus
dreieinhalb minuten nachspielzeit nichts
ändern im gegenteil südkorea store wurde
nach angezeigtem abseits und videobeweis
gegeben dann in buchstäblich letzter
minute der ersten nachspielzeit ein
weiterer treffer ins leere deutsche tor
2 0 für südkorea
lange gesichter auf der fanmeile daheim
in berlin
[Musik]
und von heute gar nicht reden
also wir sind verdient aufgestiegen
die mannschaft hat einfach nicht
gekämpft laufen nach dem ersten spiel